check out this week's must-see movies  the next show is gonna be drumroll  please a singing competition from the  creators of Despicable Me comes  sings an animated comedy about these  biggest talent competition to rock the  animal kingdom see asking me on a date  she doesn't seem that impressed  passengers is an epic sci-fi action  romance about two space travelers  awakened 90 years too soon  there's breezy I understand it's your  birthday the party's just getting  started in the fantasy film assassin's  creed a criminal must enter the memories  of an ancient ancestor to discover his  destiny here's this week's fan tissa  patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting below see  you next time on weekend ticket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]